-Mikey Day,
it is great to see you.
You know I'm a fan of yours.
You look great in a suit, buddy.
I never really see you
in a suit.
-Aw, thanks.
-Here you are,
season six on "SNL."
-Yeah.
-And crushing it as a cast
member as well as a writer.
-So nice of you.
-You're great.
Do you find yourself,
after six seasons,
still star-struck
sometimes or...?
-Yeah, occasionally.
It's usually people
who are at a taping
that you don't know
are going to be there.
The one interaction I had that
was, like --
I still think about,
in that I -- it was so awkward.
I was -- It was the season
finale on my first season
as a cast member,
and they were setting up the set
for a sketch that took place on
"Jurassic Park: The Ride."
And I played someone
who worked on the ride.
So I had a khaki shirt with
the Jurassic Park logo on it.
And I'm just standing there,
and I hear someone say,
"Hey, I know that."
And I look
and it's Steven Spielberg...
[ Laughter ]
...who, like --
I grew up a Spielberg kid,
I mean,
so instrumental
in my upbringing.
So, to go from zero
to Steven Spielberg --
You're like...
-Yeah.
And what did you say?
-I said --
And I don't know why
this came out of my mouth.
And I think about it
every once in a while
alone and just start cringing.
[ Laughter ]
He goes, "I know that,"
and is pointing at the logo.
And I said, "Yeah, the sketch
doesn't take place
in the actual park.
It takes place on the ride."
[ Laughter ]
Why? Dude!
-Wow, wow.
-Dude!
-Wow.
-That's so weird.
Why did I -- I don't know why.
-That's too much detail.
What did he do?
-He didn't say, "Hey, does this
take place in the actual park?"
"Oh, no, it takes place
on the ride."
-No, but how do you that react
to that as any human being?
-I recall him just, like,
smiling like a normal person
would and then
kind of walking away.
[ Laughter ]
And I thought about it
for so long.
It's so dumb. What?
-What if you went back in time,
and could say something?
Could you think --
What would you --
-I mean I've --
Anything but what I said, no.
I've thought about it,
and there's a line --
"I've thought about it."
I'm such a dork.
[ Laughter ]
There's a line in the movie
where John Hammond, the old man
who created Jurassic Park, says,
"Spared no expense."
So, in hindsight, I wish
I gestured to the set,
which was kind of
an elaborate set --
it had, like, a staircase
and stuff --
and said, "Spared no expense."
-Oh, yeah. Spielberg comes out
and he goes, "I know that."
And you go --
-Wait, he's pointing at
my shirt.
-Yeah, okay, so --
-Go back, go back.
-Yeah, no problem.
[ Laughter ]
-Take two.
-How tall is Steven,
do you think?
-Um...
-You're standing or sitting?
-I'm standing. Should we stand?
-Let's re-create it.
Let's re-create it.
-I'm literally looking
like this.
-Yep.
-And then --
-And I'm over here. And I go...
"Hey, I know that."
-"Spared no expense."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"You're gonna make it."
-"Thank you."
-"You're gonna make it, kid.
I want you to be
in the next 10 movies."
-"Oh, I'm gonna be
in all your movies?"
-"The rest of my career."
-"Oh, my God, thank you."
-"I love you
and I love that attitude
and I love what you said."
-"Thank you.
Did you say attitude and point
towards my waist area?"
[ Laughter ]
-"Yeah, I like your attitude."
-"I like your attitude."
[ Laughter ]
-"Thank you.
Hey, man, I like your attitude."
-"Yeah, I like yours too."
[ Laughter ]
-That's a new thing
people are doing.
"Hey, dude,
I like your attitude."
[ Laughter ]
Alright.
-"Thank my father, I guess."
[ Laughter ]
-"Thank my father"?
-Why would you say that?
[ Laughter ]
-"I had the weirdest experience
with Steven Spielberg.
He said, 'I like your attitude,'
and I said 'Thank my father.'"
[ Laughter ]
"And now I'm still
in all of his movies."
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
-Yeah, an awkward, more awkward.
-I know.
-Let's talk about your show.
"Is It Cake?"
-Yes.
-It's the number-one show.
Congratulations.
It's a big hit.
-Right. Thank you.
-On Netflix. "Is It Cake?"
People compete to see if they
can fake each other out.
And you have to slice it.
You're the deciding judge.
You go, "Is it cake?"
-"Is it cake?"
-Yeah, and --
[ Laughter ]
-It's really complicated.
-Well, here's why I would say,
you could argue that it could be
a little nerve-wracking --
because if you mess up
the slice of the cake,
it's not like you have
10 of these cakes.
They're pretty elaborate cakes.
-Right.
These bakers,
who are very talented,
bake it for like eight hours,
I think.
So they want the cut
to be right.
So, I have, like, an ear piece,
and they're like,
"Alright, here comes the cut."
-"Hey, here comes the cut.
Drum roll."
-And then you just have to
slice it right
and, like, wedge it out.
They're like, "This is
a standard cuttin' wedge, bud.
You just want to cut it
and wedge it out."
-But now you're an expert at
cake cutting.
-I mean, I'd think so, but I
got, like, a random message
on Instagram that's like, "You
cut cake like an 8-year-old."
-Alright.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm like,
"Well, that's all I have to do,
and I messed that up?"
-The Internet remains champion.
-It's undefeated.
Yeah, yeah, undefeated.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Mikey Day hosting
"Is It Cake?"
Take a look at this.
-Is it cake?
[ Dramatic music plays ]
Ah. I'm just seeing where I want
to slice this here.
♪♪
[ Clink ]
-No!
-Are you kidding?!
-It's a conch!
[ Laughter ]
-It's a conch.
Andrew, it's not cake.
You did it, buddy.
You fooled the judges.
You're up for the win.
-Thank you, guys. Thank you,
thank you, thank you.
-Kelly thought it was five.
Let's see.
-I don't want to hear any noise.
-Let's find out if this is cake.
♪♪
-[ Gasps ]
-Oh!
-Yes!
Come on now! Come on now!
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Is It Cake?" is on Netflix
right now!
Mikey Day, everybody.